at the probabilistic level
everything okay here's what hits me
here's what hits me right away okay so
there's the matrix obviously like
simulation hypothesis and then there's
also donald hoffman if you've heard of
yeah it's consciousness okay so let's
compare and contrast yours
and the matrix well let's say simulation
in general
so simulated reality and then donald
hoffman so where do you agree and
disagree with those two
hypothesis hypothesis uh
my i also have a you know i would fit
under a a simulation hypothesis too
my you know you could put my work into
that category
but mine is very different than it's not
that we're being simulated by higher
intelligent
so what happened yeah what happened
these other these other guys doing their
their virtual realities somebody asked
well you know
who's what's the computer who are the
programmers
and they're stuck for an answer yeah
they don't know you get an infinite
regress
which is illogical that doesn't make any
sense there is no
infinite regress in physics infinity
doesn't really exist as a physical thing
you know all right so we have i don't
but okay
okay so okay let's just stay on this
path for just this okay
all right all right so they come up with
something that's this
way stretch you know hand waving thing
it's our future selves or something that
are doing this
well that's a pretty that's a pretty
huge leap you know
that's one of those in a miracle
occurred so i don't
go there with that kind of a big big
leap so
i have that you know consciousness is
the computer and i can
logically explain why consciousness
would want to make this virtual reality
you know that's
that's a lot that's part of the logical
process that gets
that will be you know explained and what
the point of it is and the purpose and
the whole
thing comes out very logically but then
i have this
reality that isn't computing all the
details
it's basically computing probabilities
and it go it puts as much detail in it
as it needs
so if we're taking a measurement and now
i take my my millimeter wave radar
and i track that cannonball now it has
to
simulate that